alena Hyde is 19 years old she's doing
vocational training in mechatronic
engineering at german automotive
supplier bosch it's a profession that
requires both enthusiasm for technology
and advanced computing skills many
machines are equipped with augmented
reality that software that provides
virtual information to assist in
operations I consider myself a kind of
tech monkey I have a 3d printer at home
I use it to print stuff or make things
myself
Tobias Weber is a third year apprentice
in electronic engineering for automation
he's learning how to program a robot
which will be used increasingly in
industrial applications in the future
the latest generation of robots have
sensors that allow them to move freely
and better respond to humans obviously
someone who grew up with smartphones is
more intuitive at operating the controls
so a person who's comfortable working
with an iPad will have no problems
navigating the operational controls
because the principle is the same
during the apprenticeship trainees have
their own robot for which they can write
programs and test them out in a way the
robot becomes a kind of work colleague
Stanga I think in the future that
machines will have more independence to
move about which will make it easier to
deploy them in different places that'll
make the work increasingly more exciting
major conglomerates like Bosch have the
means to explore these innovative
technologies like smart glasses which
are being utilized more in production
but it's not only the technology that's
changing so is the workflow this
requires greater collaboration not
stinkman one connected people often only
focus on the technical details when
thinking about connected industry we
often forget that they're already
self-governing creative teams out there
working together that means there has to
be equal focus on developing social
skills that's crucial to impart to
younger people in
training whether pursuing electronics or
mechatronics a person always has to know
how to work with their hands